هل يؤدي استعاده اوكرانيا السيطره على
غالبيه اراضيها او تسليمها بهزيمتها
النهائيه في باخموت هل سيؤدي الى مفاوضات
وهل يمكن القول ايضا ان بدء المفاوضات
مرهون باستنفاذ مخزون اي من طرفي الصراع
هل ستكون هناك مفاوضات في كل الاحوال
نعم انا على ثقه من ذلك وايماني لم يتغير
بان المفاوضات ستنطلق او سنبدا بتحسسها في
غضون نهايه هذا العام والاسباب وراء ذلك
كثيره من ضمنها الهجوم الاوكراني هذا الذي
بدا وايضا الانتخابات الامريكيه وايضا في
عدد اخر من الدول التي لها علاقه بالحرب
كما ان مخصصات اوكرانيا في الموازنه
الامريكيه لها دخل لا سيما مع بدء موسم
الموازنه ومناقشتها في المؤسسات الامريكيه
والتي تبلغ ذروتها في سبتمبر واكتوبر
عندما يتم الكشف عن الارقام لمناقشتها وفي
حاله اوكرانيا خصص الكونغرس عام 2022 ما
لا يقل عن 113.1
دولار اما اداره بايدن فقد خصص اقل من 10
هذا العام ولذلك من الواضح انهما ينظران
للكونجرس لضخ المزيد ويمكن ان يكون 50
مليارا اضافيا واعتقد ان الحاله الوحيده
التي قد لا نشهد فيها مفاوضات هي عندما
تبلغ الدول الداعمه لاوكرانيا
بانها ستستمر بتزويدها بمزيد من السلاح
والمال حتى ولو كان الوضع على حاله مثل ما
كان عليه في الثالث والعشرين من فبراير
2023 والذي كانت روسيا تسيطر فيه على جزء
من لوهانسك ودونيس
والقرم والتي تسيطر عليها عمليا منذ 2014
فهل نستمر مع ذلك بتحميل دافعي الضرائب كل
هذه الاموال من دون نتيجه على الميدان وفي
حاله الولايات المتحده فان هذه الاموال لا
تاتي من المدخرات او من صناديق متخصصه
وانما من الاقتراض هنا في امريكا يتم
اقتراض كل دولار لتمويل اوكرانيا